did you see what trump said did you guys
see here about what trump said the other
day
can you play that video right there this
is adam's favorite story adam i don't
want to go today without having this
story because i know you really like the
story so let me read to you guys what
happened so uh uh uh uh i know trump
claims he doesn't drink but he sounded
even more like a drunk uncle at a
wedding tonight than usual
here he calls general milly an f an
idiot who's whose tweet is that by the
way who's that by
you you put the tweet by i'm trying this
oh this is the guy ron whoever it is
okay make this bigger
and let's play this see here's what
trump said watch this
[Music]
you mean you think it's cheaper
to leave it there so they can have it
than it is to fill it up with a half a
tank of gas and fly it into pakistan
yes sir we think it's cheaper sir that's
when i realized he was a [ __ ] idiot
[Applause]
he doesn't need to be president again he
needs his own show he needs a show by
the way go back you missed the first 10
seconds gold
nine million we have 60 70 million
dollar plans you mean you think it's
cheaper
to leave it there
so they can have it than it is to fill
it up with a half a tank of gas and fly
it into pakistan or fly it back to
what's good i mean they heard a hole
so what do you think about what he said
there
i mean the comedy show the half a tank
of gas and you get it over to pakistan
he could have been a comedian well the
first part of the clip that is cut off
is he talks about we had just had brand
new 50 million dollar airplanes 26
million helicopters yeah
i'll get i'll make this quick point and
we go
the biggest problem with trump
is the policy versus the persona he's
absolutely freaking right about the
policy we've left
billions and billions of uh of
armory and everything then planes and
helicopters and everything for our enemy
he has an absolute credible point there
and then the persona the [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that's where he loses the biggest
problem with the voter is uh they see
emotion more than they see logic so the
same problem is is
on the other end as well when it comes
to well it's the same problem with that
we have with gold the biggest problem
with the average american is i'd rather
have the cash and the gold when you know
because they'd rather have the picture
of the rock with the laser eyes
sometimes
do you miss him because think about it
we don't know where biden is we never
see him there's no prescription this guy
was always press conference
doesn't think we should have a pr anyone
uh over 70. remember they would attack
him he they would he would give a talk
about something and they would ask him
about some other unrelated thing you'd
watch him like defend it was kind of
like a lot of entertainment no we don't
even see we don't even have any press
not just him dude like you know jim
acosta thought he was an elected
official having a debate with uh with
kelly mcinerney or what's her name no
kellyanne no no imagine caitlyn
jacqueline oh god now jen sackey comes
out and says uh all the rioting is
because of the pandemic and people were
like oh well across conferences
i mean if you were a press guy and that
was on white house duty imagine how
boring this is i mean you go in there
here's the notes for the day okay well
we just shared
about
back when he was in there it was like
attack mode you know all the we just we
just circulated a stat that biden gets
more negative uh press than trump did no
way no way no
that's not my freaking opinion that was
the stat that was going on i'm not
saying i'm not disagreeing with you i'm
just saying like i remember on the
bloomberg every single day it was just
like this goes back to gerard's point to
pat's point
right now the common and american
americans are the people across the
aisle from you that guy should be
it should be a china it should be these
authoritarian regimes but instead it's
either red or blue which side are you on
but this is what he did what he did is
he pulled the veil out from the elites
he's not talking about the the angry
parent at the the student conference
like
merrick garland's going after parents
who don't want their kids being taught
critical theory now they're on terrorist
watch list with the fbi true thing by
the way merrick garland google it he's
going after general milly everything he
ever did was establish media general
milly elites elites elites elites so
that's why general millie is an elite
because he's a general yeah
general milia is an elite yeah i think
that that's pretty much i'm saying that
okay that's that's what a leader is the
guy i think i'm thinking i'm thinking
tech gazillion
maybe redefine swamp is more milly than
elite elite he's elite yeah but elite
in his eyes is much higher billionaires
of the world
without higher than one much higher
without knowing anything about
guaranteed
zuckerberg is the top pawn i mean you
know it's we're talking you know it's
you know curated bloodline go go on with
that no no that's for you know off off
the air but that's guys that have a lot
of money or something it's beyond money
it's power it's it's control it's not
the general you see these guys
occasionally just they're gone you know
i mean there's a new you know there's a
new guy is there one general that trump
actually gets along with now
mattis is out well look uh general
kelly's out
guys
millie's out why does trump not get
along with any u.s generals questions
that questions you talked about garland
okay there's a great clip you could find
on youtube where hunter biden paints
pictures and and they're selling i just
bought an nft record record prices
higher than a picasso sketch was sold
and and they asked merrick garland don't
you see a problem with this and he's
like no i don't see any yeah probably oh
it's a big it's a big deal it's
anonymous what's the big deal anonymous
buyer normal i support arts i mean come
on you know so you see this thing i mean
imagine if eric trump was painting
pictures and people were buying them for
a million dollars and he was getting the
money and this is all the best but look
you guys three billion dollar deals with
the ukraine for the big guy right all
these things that you're talking about
my hope for people back to your your
talk about you're talking about
meritocracy you like this country
because you were able to know the rules
and get to work and use your creative
intellect and ability to to build
something okay so my hope for everybody
listening is that you can start writing
gigantic income tax checks because
that's when the light switch goes off
and your thinking changes from being all
distracted about news stories and i know
all the people like i forbes i'm friends
with them okay up the road like i know
all these people and i know how stories
get produced and i know what when they
say zucker knew about i know the boom
that's not going on the the rag today
nice effort you're out of here i know
journalists make 50 grand and resent all
the people that they write about okay so
i know all this stuff but my hope is
when you're listening you can get
involved with your your pen okay writing
the check and saying what do they do
with all this money because your
thinking changes and it's not a
political thing but you start thinking
the way you're thinking of like wait a
minute this is the best restaurant you
know why i know this i've been to the
other restaurants you know and there's
rats in there and it's really bad you
know and this is why this is the best
and everything changes when you achieve
some success because your whole
perception it switches from all this
noise to what's real i i think that's a
great way to finish up we got two
minutes here very good point you just
made there uh go see what it feels like
to pay a lot of taxes and then you're
going to say what the hell am i paying
the taxes for and it's just as simple as
i remember one time uh jose andres god
bless you so one of my good friends
great guy with peruvian he would cook
very good for us on sundays
he's in la and i'm pitching him on texas
and he comes to texas we get in the car
and i go in a tollway the express lane
and it says three dollars and he says
wow we don't have this in california you
paid three dollars to go into slain i
said exactly i said here's how taxes
should work you pay taxes for what you
use i don't have to go on the express
lane but in california you have to pay
for taxes
i never use this is why i like taxes
like texas and i never thought about it
that way before so it goes back to
payload attacks and see what happens so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]